Jim Gaffigan took the stage at the
Golden Globes last night it was a mixed
bag of of an awards show I certainly
didn't watch the whole thing I saw some
of the clips going around it it was
worse even than usual but there were a
few bright spots including Jim Gaff
again
who probably had the funniest line of
the night the Golden
Globes I mean
I I can't even believe I'm in the
entertainment
industry I can't I you know it's so
unlikely I'm from a small town in
Indiana I'm not a
pedophile you
know it's funny cuz it's true that's
that's what's funny about it
and it didn't totally kill they weren't
all just dying of laughter there they
weren't dead silent either though it was
just the sort of thing they could
chuckle about because they know that
there is a pronounced pedophile problem
in
Hollywood especially as a mackerel
snapping papist you know there was this
awful sex scandal with these Pedas
priests who were molesting boys and uh
it became international news for
decades which rightly should be the
priests should be routed out of course
but the thing that was unjust about it
is that U Catholic priests are no more
likely than the clerics of any other
religious group to engage in that kind
of pedophilic sexual uh assault it it
was no more it was most pronounced and
the attacks on religion in our
civilization tend to be on the Catholic
Church which is the 2,000 year old
pillar of of the faith so you know even
in Hollywood we live in a Protestant
country socalled but every Hollywood
depiction of someone going in for a
really intent religious confession it's
always in a Catholic confessional
they're always talking to priests
they're always it it tends to come back
to that so even though other religious
Christian denominations and other
religious groups had it at a similar
rate uh the Catholics got the brunt of
it but what was even more unjust was
that put the religious groups aside
Public School teachers are multiples
times more likely to molest children
than any of the religious groups in the
United States Catholic certainly
included the public school teachers
because they're a favorite of the
Liberals they get totally off the hook
and then beyond the public school
teachers you've got Hollywood which has
a major pedo problem and they all know
it
including the attendees at the Golden
Globes perfect delivery and the delivery
was so calm and this this is something
that I think is actually a helpful
lesson in politics I was talking to a
friend of mine who's a little liberal
and gets really you know exacerbated by
politics
said Michael how are you so calm about
politics and I I think there is a a bell
curve in terms of political knowledge
and experience that will determine
whether you are calm or
crazy the people who don't know anything
about politics who have no idea what's
going on they never read a newspaper
they well if you read a newspaper you
probably don't know what's going on
either but you know they're just totally
disengaged they're very calm of course
they don't have anything to get crazy
about then when you start reading the
papers a little bit you know and you
start paying attention to some of the
corruption in our politics and you start
noticing that the guard rails might not
hold that well and our institutions are
are crumbling around us you you start to
get kind of crazy you start pulling your
hair out and then when you keep reading
all that stuff but you also read how
politics has worked for all of human
history and you start reading you start
reading history a little bit and you
start reading political philosophy and
you start recognizing that that some of
these problems just appear to be
intractable in a fallen world and they
get better and worse and they often come
in cycles and even when you got a really
good time for a few decades the bad
times are on the way there you start to
get calm
again this stuff has happened even the
most horrific kind of stuff you know
we're the stuff that Jim Gaffigan is
joking about at the Golden Globes or the
the mass massive corruption going on at
the highest levels of the federal
government you say yeah this has all
happened before we got to fix it got to
do our we got to do our level best to
fix it but this isn't
unprecedented this isn't totally
shocking this is actually kind of how
the world works and had had we just
opened our eyes and allowed ourselves to
dispel the propaganda and just see
clearly what's really going on we could
have expected it a lot of people don't
want to believe that our country could
could decay in the same way that every
great Empire has ever decayed
they don't want to admit that if there's
a riot at a shopping mall it has to be
an alien invasion not ours not our
country no way uh maybe every other
Empire and Nation not us no us too we
can maybe turn it around but we've got
to be honest first we got to see the
truth first now speaking of guys who are
really good at this guys who are really
really good at just staying calm cool
collected seeing a little bit ahead of
the curve and acting on the political
sphere and having good effect Chris
rufo
probably the fa there were other people
behind it but Chris rufo is the leading
figure in the movement to oust claudean
gay the president of Harvard because she
was a plagiarist the real reason is
because she said that it was okay to
call for the genocide of the Jews during
a congressional testimony but that's
what weakened her they still weren't
going to totally throw her out the
plagiarism Scandal cropped up as as an
academic matter that's actually a more
egregious Scandal rufo claims the scalp
the president of Harvard's gone and now
everyone's going after rufo and and my
favorite attack on this guy
guy comes from within Harvard cuz Chris
rufo he he graduated from Georgetown
that's where he went to college and then
later on he got a a degree at the
Harvard Extension school and the Harvard
Extension school is one of the schools
of Harvard but it's kind of like the
night school you know or the online
school it's the one where you go and you
can take some classes and it's certainly
non-traditional but it's a school of
Harvard University you get a Harvard
University degree at the end of it now
the libs are attacking him and they're
saying he doesn't have a real Harvard
degree it's just from that extension
school that's the fake Harvard degree
and this is such a perfect story it's
it's so classic Chris rufo it's
so I don't it's so leftist in a way it's
so clever in in how Chris has now put
his opponents in an impossible situation
because either they have to admit that
Harvard degrees can be worthless we were
told that a Harvard degree is the most
important and impressive thing ever all
the big fancy Libs who run everything
they all have Harvard degrees and they
say that that is one of the credentials
that shows why they ought to run the
entire country well hold on you've just
admitted either that a Harvard degree
can be worthless or you've got to admit
that Chris rufo has the same degree that
you guys have and so he is worthy of the
same respect that you have which is it
uh I don't
e what's funny is the actual answer is
both of them which is Harvard degrees
are increasingly worthless all of them
not just the extension school but all of
them and also Chris rufo is worthy of
much more respect than you know the
right-wingers who are actually trying to
uh help resuscitate the country are
worthy of much more respect than the
libs with all of their fancy degrees who
have destroyed it so you actually can
have both but right here what are the
libs going to give up The Prestige of
Harvard or the ability to marginalize
prominent right wiers which one are they
going to get up they don't want to give
up either really they've got to give up
both that was a great clip now you got
to ring the bell subscribe to the
Michael nlls YouTube channel we'll see
you next time